hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier am freitag zu einem
weiteren microsoft video in dem ich
bisschen erzähle was im titel quasi
schon steht ich habe die fans kennen
glaube ich sonst mal so
ja ich mache ja fast wir sollten dafür
erst mal in einer runde jump liegt denn
ich bin hier auf dem playmate server
allerdings wird glaube ich gerade in
kleiner runde
es wird einfach neben zugespielt wurde
drinnen kann jetzt hier die voller
behüten sorry weil sich die schade vom
essen schlecht ja ich mache wenn man es
selbst ich bin kein youtube was ich
koche ja auch wenn es jetzt nur nudeln
waren aber ich koche und habe keine
partnerschaft mit lieferheld und kriegt
man ganz essen und sowieso bin ich dann
nicht so schlecht denn mein klavier kam
auf die idee dass konkreter anfängt mit
minecraft videos na das ist ja echt und
war übrigens apropos wasserflasche und
apropos vitello und so ist ja gerade
einfach gar keiner steht hier gerade um
das liegt einfach daran weil ukulele weg
ist und wisst ihr warum die weg ist weil
die bei einem kumpel ist und der kumpel
kann gut filme drehen und ukulele ich
glaub ich sag jetzt einfach mal ich hab
damals einmal angekündigt dass ich voll
bock hätte auch day die blogs allerdings
habe ich dafür nicht die zeit und dann
ist er halt auf die idee gekommen hey
luca war alles klar da ist ein blog in
der luft halo kwadrat diese ukulele das
wäre doch voll leid wenn die ackermann
der die block machen würde und ich
könnte ich dabei unterstützen das filmen
und so angeht und ich bräuchte nur von
ihren patron aufnahmen und so weiter und
so fort ich dann natürlich gesagt ja
auch die ja das wäre aber ultras da
hätte ich richtig bock drauf ich habe
die kiste alter ich bin auch einfach der
letzte in dieser vertrackten liste da
rechts ich habe dann halt zugesagt und
meine jdk das wäre aber richtig cool da
hätte ich ultrabook drauf und er dann so
ja okay da machen wir das und das ging
jetzt halt voll stellt schon fertig bin
ich richtig auf dem platz da muss ich
lange dass videos jetzt auf jeden fall
fertig und ich hab's geschafft jetzt
hier hochklettern hier über die pilze
treffer und ich bin auf die kiste dass
videos jetzt fertig und
wird nämlich ich glaube morgen
hochgeladen also morgen auf einem kanal
kommt ukulele blog wie die x ich bin tag
filmt also da müsst ihr auf jeden fall
einschalten das ist aber gar nicht das
thema um das es gehen soll sondern es
soll um mein kräften niro wird
ausgesprochen ich will das gar nicht
negativ jetzt irgendwie ausdruck auch
wenns grad zur überkommen durch finden
die tatsache einfach komisch das ist wo
muss ich eigentlich hier lang lass mich
das mal eben zuerst abklären weil das
liegt für mich gerade alles irgendwie
davon hängt eine leiter aber muss ich
immer muss ich da 8c spider leiter ich
muss euch erst mal sagen wie ich davon
erfahren habe dass es sowas gibt und
zwar bin ich ja selber überhaupt nicht
mehr in dieser minecraft szene drin ich
bin tatsächlich ca verwaister setzte man
skype vielleicht von einem halben jahr
ich habe mit keinem von den ganzen
gaming leuten eigentlich richtig kontakt
außer wirklich zu max und es kay weil
das einfach gute freunde von mir sind
und zu den anderen
ich weiß nicht ich sehe auch keinen
grund irgendwie kontakt zu habe ich
feiere den content von gar keinem
irgendwie was gaming angeht in
deutschland und ich meine vom charakter
sind so viele ultra cool aber jetzt
youtube technisch habe ich halt nahezu
gar keinen kontakt mit dem man trifft
sich zwar oft bei partys und bei
irgendwelchen youtube events und so aber
so youtube technisch macht ja ich mache
alles alleine ich meinen wann update das
letzte mal ein video mit irgendeinem
anderen großen gaming youtube auf einem
kanal gesehen vielleicht vor fünf jahren
will das ist nicht zum fünften mal nicht
ich bin immer noch letzter und denkmäler
für die ganze zeit ist es voll gut wie
ich hier bin und so aber nicht
bin ich schlecht keine ahnung jedenfalls
habe ich halt zu keinem so richtig
kontakt und auch weiß ich nicht wenn ich
haben wollen würde wird bestimmt
irgendwie gehen weil ich auch voll viele
über so fragen hätte man ein so einer
bin ich nicht ich mache das nur mit
leuten auf die ich bock ab zum beispiel
mit leuten die nicht mal ein youtube
kanal haben das aber wirklich nicht das
thema sondern das sollen sie die
vorgeschichte sein wie es mir erklären
könnte und zwar dadurch dass ich mit
wirklichen namen kontakt hat der grund
warum ich in minecraft ihre nicht dabei
bin ist dass ich nicht gefragt wurde
und ich weiß nicht ob ich als trainer
bin und ob ich das nachvollziehen kann
so sachen wie war oder so viel wie so
sind wir denn schon im match auf wieso
schlägst du mich denn bruder peter
sollten wir vielleicht tatsächlich erst
mal kurz meine sachen hier anziehen so
dass ich hier so tag und jetzt habe ich
hier noch ein schwert und jetzt werden
leute geboxt oh mein gott ok ok de
achter hat er mich besiegt okay okay das
ist cool ich habe nur noch ein leben
kenneth meppen ich habe keine items bin
schlecht in dem spiel eigentlich alles
gründe warum ich nicht bei minecraft
näher oder das ist nämlich einfach der
grund ich wurde nicht gefragt ob ich
dabei sein möchte ich habe bisher auch
schon so ein paar schlechte sachen über
das projekt gehört von ein paar leuten
noch fitter als nachgefragt was das
überhaupt ist weil ich das nur noch
freunde mit bekommen habe weil ich ja
selber auch irgendwie bekommen nichts
mit ich verbringe meine zeit in social
media und nur wenn ich videos mache und
hey ich bin luca ich bin irgendwie ich
weiß nicht ich habe sehr viel zu tun und
ich glaube daran liegt so ein bisschen
also dass mein kontakt einfach zu den
leuten nicht mehr so richtig da ist mit
sie mal so noch nie wirklich da war und
irgendwie auch weil ich halt selber
einmal die woche minecraft spiele oder
so kann man den den überrasche ich jetzt
mit überraschung zur vergabe aber
barbara banga mit unglaublich ich habe
ihn kenne techno allerdings ich dachte
ich kann irgendwie dass ich was ich hab
mir nichts richtiges genommen ich dachte
ja oder lässt er die kiste fallen ich
könnte mir mal den ganzen schützen
nein nein einfach nein ich konnte
einfach nichts nehmen also noch mal der
grund warum ich dabei wird es dass mich
gefragt wurde die sache ist aber wenn
ich gefragt worden wäre tun sein
wie auch immer
angefragt worden ist tun sein ich weiß
nicht kann ich überhaupt deutsch ich
weiß nicht mal ob ich das dann
angenommen hätte weil ich ja online
bläst nein nein acom peace frieden
warum ist denn jeder so gemeinden mainka
ich glaube sogar wenn ich gefragt worden
wäre hätte ich auch nein gesagt weil
sowas wie bahro finde ich ultra geil
aber so nero oder so ich weiß nicht was
darin passiert ich habe ich darüber
nicht informiert und ich hab nur von max
gehört das ist was mit pécs ist und da
habe ich ja bisher immer nur ein
geschossen weil ich keine zeit hat mich
daran zu arbeiten keinen nerv dafür ja
nur weil ich halt gefragt wurde wollte
ich euch mal sagen dass ich nicht
gefragt wurde und das der grund dass
eigentlich ich bin da auch kein böse
also ich kann es nachvollziehen so dass
man sich denkt okay luca ist irgendwie
auch gamer youtuber aber irgendwie macht
luca nur einmal die woche minecraft
wenn's hoch kommt und es macht keinen
sinn weil damit uns allen noch nichts zu
tun hat deswegen gar nicht vorkommen ich
bin noch kein böse nur weil einige von
euch gefragt hatten wer twitter so
locker ist eigentlich mit dabei
nein bin ich nicht bin ich nicht wenig
wenn ich hier ist die antwort in dem
video in videoform ich mach
konkurrenzprodukt auf minecraft das
fünfmillionste projekt ganz viele
youtuber zusammen sind weil wir sind
alle so unoriginell ich möchte gar nicht
hetzen auch wenn es sich so anhört nur
ich bin dafür dass die dass die leute
vielleicht mal an ihrem content arbeiten
anstatt sich alle zwei tage neues
riesenprojekt auszudenken was natürlich
auch cool ist aber halt überhaupt nicht
mein ding ich weiß nicht ich bin mir
derzeit allgemein so ein bisschen gaming
mäßig selber noch eigentlich gar nicht
mehr man halt über viel realität so ich
sag mal fiel also im also im vergleich
zu früher auf meinem kanal und das ist
halt die richtung wo ich ein bisschen
hingehen will also mehr real life und
deswegen kommt beispielsweise morgen der
ukulele halten mehr so sachen freestyle
und im echten leben und ich glaube dass
hinzu gründe warum ich auch eigentlich
nicht mehr dabei sein sollte weil ich
halt einfach nicht mehr mit diesen
gaming mäßigen so richtig verbunden bin
ich hoffe dass ich dabei sein werde weil
darauf habe ich wirklich bock fall war
es einfach so an spannung pur man muss
sich in kein riesiges hauptwerk rein
arbeiten
ich will das video aber auch gar nicht
so lange halten denn ihr das video
gerade seht fliege ich wahrscheinlich
gerade nach wien weil ich bin von
freitag heute der 22 bis nächste woche
mittwoch früh also der bin ich in wien
wegen dem fantreffen da gibt es übrigens
auch noch tickets glaube ich also ihr
könnt ma lin die beschreibung schau
leisten link oben da könnt ihr noch
tickets kaufen seit aber schnell weil
das fantreffen wir schon morgen das ist
jetzt nur für die die vielleicht aus dem
urlaub ist in puncto wieder kamen und
jetzt denken wo ich wohne in wien und
bitten da und dann wenn ich ihnen
dringend braucht vielleicht gibt es auch
keine mehr zu diesem zeitpunkt gerade
uns würde ich sagen was haltet ihr von
der entwicklung die ich einschlagen
möchte was haltet ihr von nero 9
reloaded kollagens diesjährig meinen
fans einfach pizza pizza ist nice